absolutely horrifying news out of brazil
where
an extremist right winger named yair
bolsonaro
has been elected president with about 55
percent of the runoff vote and this
is part of the trumpification of
politics
with the normalization of outrageous
positions that should have been laughed
out of contention in an ideal world and
donald trump
obviously congratulating the incoming
brazilian president
this is another one of these uh sort of
data points
about the move to the right that we're
seeing in lots of different parts of the
world in terms of who is elected despite
the reality
that in many of the countries the
constituents are actually moving to the
left on political positions the united
states being a great example of that
when we've talked about healthcare
education geopolitics but that's a story
for another day
uh in europe we've seen the white
nationalists sort of xenophobic
parties uh surge we talked
with david newark last week about that
surge of extremism under trump
in the united states and then now brazil
dealing with major corruption like my
home country of argentina no question
about it
uh ends up putting in yair bolsonaro he
was just
short of 50 percent of the vote in the
first round of voting so that triggered
a runoff and received 55 percent
in round two and understand the degree
of polarization
in brazil voting's mandatory in brazil
and in the
second round in the runoff round twenty
nine percent of voters selected to
either annul their valid
or uh not cast it at all uh like
trump bolsonaro attacked the media
during the campaign his slogan
brazil above everything god above
everyone cow towed to religion by
immediately asking for a supporter of
his another senator in fact to lead the
group of people outside of his house in
prayer after news of his win
uh surfaced and was reported like trump
bolsonaro was a laughingstock
on national television satire shows for
years because he would say
wacky things just like donald trump and
now they are both
presidents of the of of their respective
countries or bolsonaro soon will be
like trump bolsonaro thinks that climate
change is a hoax he's previously said
that
he would withdraw brazil from the clan
climate agreements of the paris climate
agreement who does that
sound like he said that global warming
is nothing nothing more than quote
greenhouse fables he previously said
i am in favor of a dictatorship a regime
of
exception he's a supporter of torture
previously saying i'm in favor of
torture you know that
and the people are in favor as well he
is blisteringly homophobic
saying quote i will not fight or
discriminate but if i see
two men kissing in the street i'll hit
them
asked about the possibility of what if
you had a gay kid
he said quote i would be incapable of
loving a homosexual child
i'm not going to act like a hypocrite
here i'd rather have my son die in an
accident
than show up with some mustachioed guy
for me he would have died and speaking
to a congresswoman on television he said
i'm a rapist now
i would never rape you because you do
not deserve it
[ __ ] quite a guy on salary equity
he said i would not employ a woman with
the same salary
of a man but there are many women who
are competent
this is sort of a blend of donald trump
and rodrigo duterte from the philippines
and he has won
in brazil it's the trumpification of
american politics
this is unfortunately an existential
threat to the progress of humanity on
the planet now you will hear from the
right
that the left is overblown blown
that the left is being hyperbolic when
it comes to the fears
that we say we have about donald trump
about saudi arabia about kim jong-un
about rodrigo duterte duterte about
bashar al-assad except for
those on the left who don't really seem
to have a problem with bashar al-assad
who we've spoken about
and with yeah your bolsonaro in brazil
uh if that's your position you're not
paying attention
to the existential threat that exists
when you have authoritarians who don't
believe in climate change
who are focused on all the wrong issues
mostly
and are on the wrong side of the right
issues that they're actually paying
attention to this is an existential
threat
to the progress of humanity and it's
something we all have to come to terms
with
and the only solution is going to be to
demand
change by voting and maybe even more as
i've talked about before
civil disobedience general strikes we're
going to have to continue talking about
that